re
ん
佐藤卓です
僕は廃棄物最終処分場の技術管理の仕事を
しています
皆さんは最終処分場って聞くとどんな
イメージでしょうか
一面のゴミ
こんなイメージでしょうか
昔はこうでしたが
現代はこうです
いったいどこにゴミがどれだけ埋まって
いるのか全然分かりませんよね
これは
環境の影響最小限にするための厳しい法律
があって僕たちがそれに沿って管理して
いるためです
ゴミが運び込まれてもすぐに土を大決まり
があります
だからゴミが見えないんです
この頭は
処分場を切った断面図です
配管を通じて酸素ゴミの中に取り込ませる
ことによって自然に浄化が進んでいきます
また雨が降って滲み出てくるお水は
コンクリートや専用のシートを使って
漏れ出さないように守ってるんです
このように陸上でゴミを
埋め立てることお粥状目立てと言います
陸上目立ってのほかに改名メタてまいり
ます
海に建設された処分場で同じようにゴミを
埋め立てるんです
ここ清水にも
開始まっていう解明目立ての処分場があり
ますが僕も同じタイプの処分場を担当して
います
海面処分場
陸上と同じ法律で管理しています
でも地面の中では状況が全く異なります
陸上目立てでは内部に酸素を取り込むこと
で浄化が進んでいきますが解明目立ては
ゴミが水没しているために酸素を取り込む
ことができないんです
つまり浄化のスピードが
陸上目立てよりかなり遅くなります
服は毎日の仕事の中で海岸埋め立ての上官
の難しさを肌で感じ
こんなことを考えるようになりました
もし災害でこの堤防が壊れてしまったら
浄化が完了していないゴミがー
未来にこのまま残してしまうのか
何かできることはないのか
自然をより良い形で残したい
僕は
水没したゴミを浄化することを決心しまし
た
僕が大学で学んだのは航空工学
当時は専門は違うし研究者でもない
実験は仕事以外の時間で資金はお小遣い
でも僕は増加をしたいという思いで
とにかく
実験を開始しました
まず僕は
粥状目立てと改名目と手のその大きな違い
を考えました
それは
海面埋め立てはゴミが水没しているので
酸素
奥まで届けることができないということ
です
水没していても酸素を届けることができれ
ば上下ができるかもしれない
でも空気を送っても泡になって浮かんで
しまうので
深く浸透させることができないんです
ではいったい何を使って山荘届ければいい
のでしょうか
僕は発想を切り替えて
水に邪魔をされてダメならその水に山荘を
溶け込まして届ければどうだろうと考え
ました
この方法には大量のきれいな水が必要です
でも処分場の中にはすでにお水が溜まって
いて
それが流れ出さないように守っているん
です
そうなれば答えは1つ
溜まっているお水をきれいにして上官に
使えばいい
浄化に使って水が汚れたらまた綺麗にして
再利用すればいい
循環型の浄化の仕組みがつくれる
そう考えました
ところがここで大きな問題がありました
それは浄化装置です
最終処分場のお水って本でもないんです
硫化水素も発生していて大の大人が
ひっくり返るくらいのすごいに予定です
こんな水をきれいにするほどの装置は彼は
だけでも数千万
維持費だけで僕の給料が全部なくなります
でもこれがなければ前に進めません
よし
ないならつくろうということで
造花装置の開発も始めました
とはいってもできは強敵です
僕は小さい頃
じいちゃんが
自然からは教わることが多いんだよと言っ
てた事を思い出して自然の仕組みを参考に
することにしました
水を本当の意味で浄化ができるのは
やっぱり自然の力なんです
薬品を使えばすぐ効果が現れますが最後に
残るのは薬品なんです
フィルターを使えばそれは
汚れ起こし取っただけです
でも自然の力は
汚れの成分を分解して最後に残るのは水と
土なんです
先ほど
このお水を
まるで敵のように表現をしましたが
そうではなく実はこれも微生物の分解の
過程だったんです
自然の力を借りて水を浄化する装置
僕は試行錯誤を重ね約1年
低コストが水質浄化装置いうを完成させ
ました
この図をご覧下さい
現在のいうは6つの処理工程を利用でき
ます
お水を取り込み
かき混ぜ
酸素を加え生物処理1
そして生物処理に最後に放流です
これら全てを一つのポンプで稼働させて
同時に各ユニットに空気を送り込む仕組み
です
これが
1サラリーマンでも作ることができる低
コストの正体です
実はこれはホームセンターですべて材料は
揃えます
心臓部は
強力な水流と細かい気泡を使います
生物処理ユニットはそこの水域に存在する
微生物をユニット内に取り込んで
そして育てます
つまりそこに
微生物を持ち込んだりするようなことはし
ません
薬品や元々そこになかった微生物を
持ち込んでしまえばそれは自然ではない
からです
では気になるその性能です
処理水のデータを見れば効果は歴然ですが
浄化した水はある程度
きれいな環境が必要なゲンゴロウなどの
生物が進めるようになります
処理能力は
家庭用100ボルトなら30トン
この30トンを身近なものに例えると
お風呂が
150杯分です
ユニットの構成を組み替えて200ブルー
つ専用機にすると
池などのもっと大きな場所を浄化できます
そう中は
コンピューターなしで自動運転ができる
設計ですがコンピュータをノッサ場合研究
の強力なアシスタントになります
いうは僕に代わって24時間実験を継続さ
せ
データを取り続けてくれます
言うと僕はいつもスマートフォンで
つながっていて映像を見ながらのリモート
コントロールもできます
実は実験をしてデータを取ってくれていた
のは装置いうなんです
僕はデータを見て喜んでいただけ
だから仕事をしながらでも膨大なデータを
取ることができました
こうして完成した強力な浄化装置
言うとともに最終処分場の土地の浄化を
スタートしました
結果は
自分でもびっくり大成功
ビッグっ
がとうございます
この成果は最終処分場技術システム研究
協会
通称 nsa から認めていただき研究
成果を発表させていただきました
この経験は
僕の研究の精度を高めるきっかけとなり
エビ生の先生方には大変感謝しています
また僕の研究をいつも支えてくれた住吉
工業の中川さんには心から感謝しています
僕の研究は仕事のためではありません
また寺駅を得るつもりもありません
僕の目的は
自然をより良い形で残すこと
僕は
そう中を
本当に必要とする方には
無償での技術提供を行います
もし
そう中が
水が汚れて困っているところで逆に立つの
なら
もし本気で何とかしたいという方達がいる
のなら
いうの技術を提供します
もしかしたらなんでこの人ただて技術提供
するとか言ってんの
裏があるんじゃないとか
えっ
思っている方もいるかもしれませんね
でもこれには僕なりの理由があるんです
今お話ししたアイデアは
今は亡き息子と一緒に過ごした期間に
考え出したものです
僕は
息子を失った
悲しみを
研究に没頭することで紛らわせました
短すぎる人生をへ
彼が天国に旅立ってから装置として形にし
たものです
息子の言うという名前には
人のために生きることができる
優しい子になってほしいと
願いを込めたものでした
僕は完成した装置に
言うという名前に込めた思いを託しました
この想いをもっと生きてほしかった
彼に代わって話してほしい
僕はそう願って同じ名前をつけたんです
装置が完成して僕は二人の子供を授かり
ました
これから彼らが生きる未来
今は亡き息子が生きるはずだった世界
装置言うには
未来を生きる
子どもたちのために生き続けてほしいと
願っています
そう中のリス提供
実はこの話は
具体的な要望があって
すでに動き出している話です
そう中は今年インドの子供たちのために
生活水準の
低い地域の水質浄化に迎えます
安価に作ることができ
メンテナンスフリーで ru は
経済格差により手付かずの地域の水問題
解決にうってつけです
そして国内にも海面処分場や池など
浄化を必要とするところはまだまだあり
ます
また汚れた水は
僕たちが作ってしまうんです
僕たちが生きている限り
止めることができません
でも
僕たちにもできることはあるはずです
僕自身は息子の名前を受け継いだ
装置言うとともに
人と
自然界との懸け橋となれるように研究を
続けていきます
今ここに立っている僕は皆さんから見てん
特別な人間に見えますか
研究を紹介いただいて
ここをテックスに立たせていただいたこと
は僕も正直嬉しいです
でも研究を始めた時にはただの
サラリーマンだったんです
今もサラリーマンですけどね
僕が特別な立場
特別な人間ではないからこそコスト面で
優れたいうが生まれました
これからの世界を良くしたいという
気持ちと行動は特別な人である必要はあり
ません
ひとりひとりができることは違います
生み出すものも違います
でも
僕たち一人ひとりが
何かを良くしようと考え
行動したときに
僕たちは誰かにとって特別な人になるん
です
自分も何かやってみよう
そんな人が
一人でも増えればきっと状況は良くなり
ます
そんなあなたに
いうが寄り添い
共に生き続けることができれば
この上なく幸せです
ありがとうございました